there are no road names
just alleyway numbers
it's dark dirty and a side of climate
change you don't expect
and rarely see
every year climate change is forcing
half a million bangladeshis from their
rural homes
most end up in dakar city slums where
space
is running out salaam alaikum
no johan begum arrived last year from
the coast
with her family she tells us they had a
small farm
but now they're renting a two-room shack
with no windows and barely enough room
to move
right to
is
bangladesh is on the climate change
front line
it's geographically vulnerable to rising
sea levels and stronger cyclones
most climate migrants were fishermen or
farmers
they've seen their homes livelihoods
even their land
disappeared
until then they're stuck in a place
where landlords
some with political connections charge
high prices for unsafe homes
electricity is connected illegally
sewers flood when it rains
but what use is a dustpan against
monsoon rain
and a drain put in to help does the
reverse
that brings the water but that's
bringing the water in you want the water
to go the other way
yes and the water is dirty he says it
smells
dakka is now the most crowded city in
the world
on the verge of yet another strict
covert 19 locked down
thousands of migrant workers have
escaped for their rural homes
climate change migrants don't have that
option
over the last 20 years bangladesh has
lifted millions of people
out of poverty
at the capitol's main port you can see
the trade and industry that has expanded
the economy
grown the middle class but also drawn
people to a city that now
can't cope daca is crumbling taka is
crumbling under
other people coming here and do you
think this is the side of climate change
that people just don't
see and don't realize exists yeah they
don't connect
this reality with climate change because
because they think it's coastal areas
this is uh this is something that's
going to happen in the future
but this is dystopia this is happening
in real time
and i think the world doesn't know
enough about it but
people here can't just wait she
understood english
are you understanding in one alleyway we
meet
tanya akhtar who's 18.
ed her family moved here to escape
rising sea levels
she hopes this small school run on the
family bed
can somehow do something i
teaches them english bengali
myth they are
they doesn't speak english
i am little i'm little but i try my best
to teach them
this is menara this is tanya's mother
and she wanted to tell us how proud she
felt of her daughter
for doing this teaching but she wanted
to try and say it in english so
tanya's doing a little bit of impromptu
teaching as well
so that she can say on camera of how
proud she is of her daughter
do you want to say it
tell us how you feel about your daughter
i feel proud
i feel proud proud
to my daughters to my daughter
in climate change there are tipping
points a moment from where there is no
return
people here want to go back home but to
what
for many this is now their future